how's it going rest my name and welcome
to gmod crying stuff you should do the
intro I'm not good at them
have a chair wait why did I check out
did you lie it
Hey look at this bottom Oh what like if
you click on this ambience stops what
this is stuff for you - yes we should
probably progress with these spooks math
on gmail hey I told you it wasn't a lie
what the chat Oh
oh my god alright you should let him
enter first whoa
answer already okay I didn't we didn't
have to cheat to do that like security
we have to check through that I have a
bottle of wine or beer the guard got
drunk on his job and you're now locked
in there forever
not done no I'm not you lie I'm sorry
can we go here the chair can don't let
me cry have a shovel
take it a face Oh what is in here
there's coffins back here whoa really
yeah Oh spooky it's us focus danger
let's go that crack sounds like a great
place
Wow what is this this is where they burn
the bodies ah ah sweets
oh there is I don't like these places it
stirs oh no I don't want to go down
there I want to go down here there's a
morgue oh oh I'm sorry I need to squeeze
through its contained area oh you can
open them oh don't be at it go back in
are there any month don't let there be
an ID fine bye done dairy cry alright
there's a switcher and yes oh my god
that's less creepy Oh what have I done
why did you do okay let's go upstairs
the bathtub is playing Wow alright Emma
wants it put this it's an elevator see
okay so you put the bodies down there
done like right Jagger venture awaits
fine I come with you
down in the morgue a lot of adventure
alright that was the convention let's go
what it wasn't me what a me did it and
the sofa wasn't crying that's beautiful
thank you alright we shouldn't have
entered there but we did anyway that's
how we roll that's how we get out of a
I'm scared of UK look horrible any
problems
Oh beautiful leave me alone like you're
horrible oh you can open everything
Kenya yes this one doesn't open I wanna
go in here me hey there's thingy oh you
know that is blue there's a thingy
there's all the things I thought it's
austere somewhere oh there's graves cuz
you're gonna tell Marcia no Oh buddy
thank you
I'm not sure this is helping me up to
bed Duncan oh this [ __ ] don't panic you
have a oh wait what is it no more gates
yeah
judge one step at a time crying all
right
that doors not opening that blanks out
of a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] you can hear
everybody r2 he's like in this doors I'm
ha probably son of it that was just our
friend mr. g-man's that son of a drivin
shining man all right hey this is a big
door over here that I opened okay I'm
I'm glad we didn't go that first yes
rise and shine crying that's gone here
okay I'll let you go first now cuz this
tomb of King Tut nope it's not fine I'll
get no mummies today I love no I love
Noi's
little better yeah I think I like the
big house okay we go here I think so no
I don't think that it's not even a house
is just like a big sandwich open door
there's trees growing inside the crying
cried Scrooge Church whatever okay you
go fetch my aunt anyway I I trusted um a
week's come deserve planks of wood hi we
must sacrifice the scholar oh there's a
Christ
now wait no let's go we must sacrifice
the baby ah geez or a cult
dammit yep dammit it's levitating that's
never a good sign
oh geez now this ghost got here spooky
huh did you throw that you are a pot
inspector and I'm stuck okay okay okay I
got this I got this
check it out wizardry okay now is it
Rick look I put a chair on you oh thank
you yes thank you
don't worry buddy this is how I roll
rise and shine I don't know why I did
everything look rise and I can't move
man yeah we're stuck now a good job man
he trapped us in his glue trap
whoa I got cherry oh jeez oh my god
Freeman rise and shine
how do you do buddy go yeah whatever are
you responding with the world's and I
and I did yes I don't even know if it's
necessary but do an inch okay right
let's find the key find the key
yep Oh how's it going bros my name is
she said your name yeah yeah I got high
expectations of you finding the key I'm
never gonna find that game about it all
right all right
I think oh the door open Wow from me
just clicking the key that's amazing
Craig come here man why do you have that
skin man why do you not I'm a doctor I
judge anything it's a nice gray okay you
can be careful screamish man Bobby oh
hey that's a brick get out of here
what am i doing I didn't do it come on
[Music]
it's not like it's taking the music beat
it was the drop man goddamn drunks all
those drops you hear the crowbar man oh
I think it's in here
okay break it better tie it up for this
box
wait come on
okay that's how I roll whoa sorry man
that's okay I don't know if we're
supposed to go in here all right we
don't defend that wasn't necessary very
much so
okay right the hell there we go I don't
want to go into beatboxer Wow Oh B bucks
maybe there's something behind is that
that's thing I'm going back home don't
go home crap
break this bro of course yeah break yeah
and ever yeah yeah hey dad don't don't
leave me alone I didn't I didn't do it
on purpose but ah
Nolan might leave nothing here hey hey I
like that I'm on the half light posters
oh my god like they're they're pretty
damn well do you hear this crime oh I
think it's the posters
hey that ain't it good job thank you
okay I don't know what are you doing
we're going in here Oh Oh
beatbox good job good good guy I know
there they were all open oh oh geez
what this is skeleton up oh no we're
gonna make it gum alive gelatin I can't
go over last night hello you better not
come a night dark okay close your eyes
uh open them no all right we should call
him Jeremy I already got an apron what
Jeremy does not like Jeremy anymore he
burped let's go Jeremy you're coming
with us
Adventure jeez not good Jeremy can have
fun all right
why are we well what what no more
beatbox please Jeremy I don't like it uh
going through the store music so happy
say that Jerry can you grab Jeremy for
me I will all right come on let's go you
weird skeleton thing oh no I don't wanna
go first here yeah Jeremy go first okay
yeah let him go thing go check if it's
safe Jeremy do it good work oranges and
lemons ah this way
ah as well all right I have the crowbar
whoa what I think we're going here
should we just leave Jeremy what yes yes
Jeremy's brings these things to us sir
where did he go anyway
Jeremy was asleep all right let her
sleep in the milk just like he always
wanted
that's no I can't come back to me wait
we went so far where are you I got my I
find the clipboard with the password you
found it
Jeremy's down here did you find the
clipboard with the password just find it
oh that was because I'm sorry okay I try
to come back to you man ah you are fast
man q I'm sorry about that hard feelings
alright that's where we need to find a
clipboard and I guess when you have to
go here to find it without killing
anyone I don't know if I should have the
Crowborough this
oh just scare like two seconds ago they
funny yeah